[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique verte et france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec patrick
mennucci conseiller municipal ps de la
ville de marseille face à vous nicolas
bailly ce ancien député ps parmi les
fondateurs de la république en marche
merci de faire partie de nos
contributeurs à partir d'aujourd'hui on
va vous retrouver tous les quinze jours
pour débattre sur ce plateau
invité également serge federbusch tête
de liste et mais paris candidat à la
mairie de paris liste soutenue par le
rassemblement national et le parti
chrétien-démocrate et arnaud benedetti
spécialiste en communication politique
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france et c'est à la une cette
semaine regarder à moins de deux mois
des élections municipales les
candidatures se précise pour la
république en marche une dizaine de
ministres sont entrés dans la course
cette semaine à l'instar de didier
guillaume pour la mairie de biarritz qui
a face à lui un autre membre du
gouvernement
quelle est la stratégie du parti
présidentiel pour ce scrutin cher aux
français on va essayer d'y voir clair
d'autant qu'une circulaire du ministère
de l'intérieur fait hurler l'opposition
un texte adressé au préfet change les
règles du jeu pour ce qui est de
l'identification positive des futurs
élus au risque de fausser la lecture des
résultats selon ses détracteurs écouter
il ne faut pas dénaturer l'élection
municipale
il faut pas non plus dénaturer ce que
souhaitent et décident les élus de
déclarer je pense notamment dans les
communes inférieur 1 à 9000 habitants et
je dois dire que j'ai attiré l'attention
solennellement du premier ministre je
pense que cette circulaire cette
circulaire est pas conforme aux valeurs
démocratiques qui sont les nôtres
une circulaire qui serait pas conforme
aux valeurs démocratiques a dit gérard
larcher arnaud benedetti c'est quoi
cette circulaire précisément qu'il a été
distribué d'abord le discours de gérard
larcher lors de la vue
lors des voeux à la presse parlementaire
était un discours très offensif il faut
le signaler on avait un président du
sénat qui était quand même dans une
posture d'opposition qui était une
posture de position forte et déterminée
circulaire tout simplement
elle vise à ne plus comptabiliser dans
la distribution des grandes forces
politiques nationales
les élus qui peuvent éventuellement être
républicain qui peuvent être
éventuellement socialiste et qui ne le
sont pas forcément pour certains d'entre
eux dans les communes de moins de 9000
habitants comme le comble reportage le
dit très bien ça veut dire que bien
évidemment ça brouille ira quand même à
la marge
la lecture de ces résultats puisque vous
avez des communes de 5000 habitants au
de 6000 habitants où vous avez des
étiquettes politiques qui sont
clairement et explicitement identifiez
vous avez des candidats socialistes vous
avez des maires socialistes dans des
communes de 5000 habitants vous avez des
maires républicains dans les communes de
5000 habitants
donc en effet ça donne le sentiment en
tout cas pour les oppositions pas
seulement pour l'opposition pour les
oppositions bain de brouiller la lecture
des résultats qui sortiront des urnes à
l'issue des élections municipales en
tout cas c'est le reproche qui est fait
par les oxymètres y viennent aussi en
quoi ça peut être avantageux pour la
république en a je crois que c'est très
simple la république en marche qu'on le
voit donne les élections précédentes
c'est à dire qu elle et elle est plus
forte dans les métropoles est et dans
les villes importantes que dans les
villes où les petites villes ou ou même
les campagnes et donc le fait de ne pas
donner d'étiquette politique peu près à
la moitié de l'électorat français s'est
un peu plus de la moitié sont % de
l'électorat français ça veut dire qu on
aura
contrairement
aux dernières élections où on avait les
forces politiques et puis ensuite il y
avait divers ni gauche ni droite et y en
avait évidemment beaucoup dans les
petits villages on aura pour 40% de 2 %
des communes
voilà mais oui mais sa cause à 97% mais
comme une évidence il ya trente-six
mille hommes fading qu'on sente bien
compte de ce que ça veut dire mais c'est
surtout en terme d'électorat cadeaux
fera locaux faisait ça qui est quand
même je crois est l'intérêt sur le
nombre de jeunes qui sont allés voter
il croit que 40% des inscrits qui
pourront savoir si dont les français
pour savoir quel est le vrai score de la
république dans manche pour moi y
revenir le jugement qui va très faible
mais pour des raisons structurelles
d'ailleurs pas ce qu'il manque ce n'est
pas ce qui manque avec annie là il n'y a
pas de gagnant du parti socialiste de l
ère du front faits et s'est excusé c'est
une volonté du pouvoir de dissimuler
l'échec évident qu'il va subir lors de
l'élection militants attention on n'a
pas de boule de cristal je suis dans la
rue je vois juste sur les circulaires et
on reviendra après avec monsieur minuti
sur les résultats futurs dans marche aux
élections municipales sur les
circulaires il faut deux choses rappeler
que c'est une demande des élus locaux et
que l'association des maires de france
s'est félicitée de
de cette circulaire en mettant peut-être
un bémol sur la barrière des 9000 et pas
sur la barrière des visiteurs 3000 la
vérité la vérité c'est que la demande de
baroin c'est une demande est sur les
communes de 3700 habitants ce qui est
pas exact l'association des maires de
france sur banshee s'est félicité
aujourd'hui de cette circulaire et après
quand j'entends le discours de gérard
larcher ce qui m'amuse c'est que on veut
masquer les on nous accuse de vouloir
masquer les étiquettes des candidats
sauf que dans les grandes villes
martine aubry à lille le candidat de
droite à bordeaux partiront sans
étiquette essayant de masquer le plus
possible merci à ces cas là c'est pas
vrai nom mais sévices et non mais c'est
faux les candidats partent pas ça les
étiquettes et il se déclare la
préfecture la préfecture et vous verrez
que martine aubry
le problème c'est qu'on ne prête qu'aux
riches et on a de nombreux motifs de se
méfier de ce que fait la république en
marche depuis le début si c'était vous
voyez si ça venait d'un pouvoir vous
vous présentez à paris à la tête des
mets paris un petit parti associé
voilà est-ce que c'est compliqué
justement quand on est un petit parti de
faire campagne pour ces municipales
bon on a des soutiens de partie plus
important évidemment c'est compliqué
parce que reviendra ensuite sur le sujet
donc qui nous préoccupe à savoir la
république en marche et c'est pratique
mais bon pari c'est 529 candidats peu ou
prou voyez avec la parité
donc c'est un système démentiel qui a
hérité en fait de gaston defferre 1983
les premières élections municipales avec
quelque chose qui à mon sens devrait
être revu un peu aussi à marseille ou à
lyon à savoir qu'il ya trop d'élus c'est
il ya clairement trop début il ya eu en
plus une séparation entre les
conseillers d'arrondissement et les
conseillers de paris qui n'est plus qui
n'est plus de ce monde enfin qui n'a
plus de raison d'être et donc tout ça
fait que on devrait avoir moins d'élus
et des listes isc qu'ils soient plus
compact et ça serait beaucoup plus
visible alors ça c'est le premier à nous
parler d'art et fluide en marche alors
on n'arrivait qu'aux marche le problème
le problème c'est que on est habitué aux
manipulations au fait de se présenter
parfois sous des étiquettes et des
couleurs ambigu au fait d'essayer de
débaucher l'ordre quand on voit par
exemple
les pratiques de monsieur griveaux à
paris vous voyez qui va essayé de
débaucher des maires sortants ou
d'anciens maires aussi mais en parti
socialiste que en fait à droite avec
avait avec delphine bürkli dans le 9e
enfin et c'est du débauchage parce que
c'est vraiment mais on est face à un
pouvoir qui a l'habitude de la
manipulation
ils viennent fois qu'ils viennent de ce
pouvoir qui nous permettait de terminer
et ensuite vous pourrez me répondre
autant que vous le souhaitez donc quoi
qu'il vienne de ce pouvoir c'est le
problème du de l'individu qui a déjà
volé et ensuite dont on se méfie vous
voyez eh bien il a mauvaise réputation
et monsieur négation réputé d'autres
partis ont mauvaise réception c'est pas
bien ça va tourner à fuir il y a il
voulait prendre la banque s'interroge
pas sur ses motivations rappelons et
innovation attendait sur monsieur les
motivations de la république en marche
on les comprend très bien on ce dont on
parle là c'est de la technique et du 2
mai de mode opératoire et les voilà sur
le mode opératoire moi je maintiens que
cette circulaire était voulu moi même je
suis encore jusqu'aux prochaines
municipales conseiller du d'une ville
qu'on se le dise pas d'une vie de 8 500
habitants dans le pas de calais j'avais
été élu sous l'étiquette socialiste à
l'époque il y avait dix membres du parti
socialiste sur une liste de 29 nom et y
avait dix neuf membres de la société
civile qu'on à qui on impose et
l'étiquette parti socialiste à la
préfecture parce que tous les élus sont
déclarés comme étant élu du parti
socialiste étaient au départ quand elle
a appelé ses le formulaire pour savoir
quel est le nom de la liste et à kehl a
aussi blessé le liquide peut-être
les réactions aussi c'est bon j'ai quand
même pris un certain nombre de
formulaires cerfa dans ma vie on va dire
de déclaration de candidature donc c'est
très clair et les gens qui se présentent
des élections savent très bien en
plissant le formulaire en signant la
formule sacramentelle
ils savent qu'elle est la tête de liste
et donc ils savent parfaitement quelle
couleur politique et lorient très bien
comment ça fonctionne dans l'est dans la
pratique un peu douteuse mais la
pratique est de savoir pourquoi les
français ne sont pas perdu un peu dans
cette élection municipale entre ce qui
est bon il ya au tour d'élections
municipales qu'il y a deux communes en
france donc elles sont toutes
différentes et il ya des contextes
locaux qui pèse aussi le sur
l'orientation niveau mais s'ils
voulaient alors en effet cette cette
circulaire plus tôt selon cette
circulaire pour ce pose problème s'il ya
aujourd'hui polémique c'est qu'elle pose
problème manifestement et que de toute
façon les oppositions ont compris qu'il
y avait là malgré tout une difficulté de
la pour la république en marche à sa
culture et au local si vous voulez le
problème de la république en marche
c'est que c'est une formation politique
qui a gagné par le haut tout de suite ce
qui est rarissime dans l'histoire d'un
cinquième ce qui est avec le général de
gaulle ce que j'aimerais excusez moi il
ya quand même une petite différence sa
trajectoire historique du général de
gaulle n'était pas celle d'emmanuel
macro il sait pas tout à fait c'est pas
du navet s'est pas fait c'est pas faire
offense à emmanuel macron que de ne pas
le comparer au général de gaulle en
l'occurrence l'histoire n'est pas la
même la trajectoire n'est pas la même
mais jimmy sur ce qu'un espace de 65 ans
a dit on d'un côté avec l'essai fillon
et de l'autre côté avec le mrp et parce
qu'il n'avait pas d'ancrage local
oui je suis je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord sauf que le sauf qu'ils n'ont
pas tout à fait prêt parce que le rpf
exister sous la quatrième république il
y avait un impôt il y avait une
implantation politique y avait une
implantation locale
le rpf n'avait pas tout à fait la même
histoire que la république en marche la
république en marche et une formation
politique tout à fait neuve et c'est
d'ailleurs l'exploit qu'a réalisé
emmanuel macron ils ont gagné par le
haut le problème c'est qu'ils ont gagnés
par l'eau sans ancrage local
allez quelques notables qui fait bien
sûr la défaite
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
voit bien que la stratégie locale à
l'occasion de ces élections municipales
de la république en marche est une
stratégie extrêmement hésitante
vous voyez bien que dans un certain
nombre d'endroits ils vont soutenir des
candidats plutôt à droite en essayant
de s'inscrire dans une dynamique de mer
sur temps dans d'autres endroits ça sera
plutôt des élus de centre gauche
et puis vous avez aussi des stratégies
autonome comme à bordeaux où finalement
on est très surpris que la république en
marche ne vienne pas soutenir le
candidat d'alain juppé mais vas quand tu
va soutenir un candidat modem
donc on voit bien qu'on est face à une
formation politique qui essayent de
tenter une implantation territoriale
dans un contexte national qui est un
contexte national bien évidemment
difficile parce que c'est le parti au
pouvoir et qui a pris et que à partir de
après deux ans et demi
bien évidemment demande à un parti au
pouvoir est en général c'est dans
l'opinion de ces stratégies du coucou
c'est à dire qu'on fait ça sont là où il
ya déjà quelqu'un patrick mennucci
est-ce que cela et c'est faute de deux
candidats long mais je crois que la
préparation des élections municipales a
été marqué lrm par plusieurs étapes
d'abord il ya une étape de fourie
rappelez vous après les élections
européennes
voyez tout un tas de gens c'est à dire
aller revendiquer la la la candidature
pensant que le score de la liste
européenne
porté par emmanuel macron tellement on a
oublié le nom de la tête de liste allez
allez allez allez se dupliquer dans une
élection municipale est renommé et il a
raison la principe d'une élection
municipale c'est d'être municipal c'est
à dire que la question s'était même pas
de communauté annie métropolitaine mer
on n'y est pas encore allé municipal la
question elle est vraiment porté
localement et localement le deuxième
élément qui avait marqué la lrm c'est la
constatation la surprise à partir du
mois de septembre
deux sondages calamiteux pour ses
canines c'est à dire que je vois un
chômage qui a été commandé par l air qui
a été rendu public
ares à saint-etienne et à oman où des
députés de la république à marche
opposé au maire de droite étaient entre
5 et 8 pour ça et puis tout ça ça peut
se multiplier
on a vu d'ailleurs à marseille
hier le sondage où le candidat l'appui
que manche et à lui pour ça donc il n'y
a pas eu de décret mentation de ce
qu'ils sont troisièmement des divisions
on a un parti voilà une partie qui est
extrêmement divisé sur les voiries
d'abord et le clac de co2 des
municipales en boîte selon moi des gens
sous sa moye est d'aider des trucs que
général von savoye en travers sa
politique et pas toujours nerfs est donc
divisée mais là et à lille à marseille à
paris et puis ensuite on peut décemment
à auxerre fils l'exemple de bordeaux est
un exemple est incompréhensible
politiquement la maire alain juppé on a
un premier ministre qui est l'ami
d'alain juppé
soutenu par le modem et on a un gars qui
est plutôt quelqu'un d'intéressant qui
est un ami des manuels va compliquer les
bidons pouces à 7 connu effectivement à
la stratégie dont vous parlez celle du
goût passe quand on n'arrive pas comme
ça on va se mettre en lice mais
l'incendié du coucou est une conséquence
regardez par exemple à toulouse et à
nice ans qu'il n'y aura pas d' il n'y
aura pas de candidat contre moon dengue
ou estrosi et ils ont l'investiture à la
fois de l air et de la république en
marche et qu'est-ce qui viennent le dire
tous les deux nous quand on est
justement quand on mène un parti qui n'a
pas une envergure nationale
si en partie les règles du jeu sont si
démocratique que ça selon vous pardon
j'ai pas les règles que je peux faire
maintenant dans quelques salons est bon
en fait ce qui se passe et qu'on
effectivement eu en partie qui est assez
mal organisés qui était fondée sur une
espèce d aventure individuelle et qui a
du mal à trouver ses marques qui en plus
et surtout je crois que le problème dans
cette histoire c'est que une espèce de
morgue à la tête de l'état et dans la
façon dont les choses sont en fait
décidé donc la directive sans trop se
dire qu'on prend les gens pour des
imbéciles alors par exemple quelle était
la stratégie de mac roja paris la
stratégie et paris c'était aussi
important pour l'ensemble des
municipales il fallait dissimuler le
risque
en fait dit
mais d'un point de vue de communication
et d'un point de vue médiatique d'un
échec de la république en marche aux
municipales en france donc on a très
bien vu ce qui s'est passé la république
en marche et a mis le paquet sur un
candidat qui dispose d'un budget
faramineux qui vient du gouvernement
donc griveaux et qui était censée avec
une armada médiatique qui pilonnait tout
le monde un peu comme pour l'élection de
macron avec des couvertures des
interviews partout c'est ce qui a permis
largement une élection de macron 2017
eh bien ils ont voulu reproduire la même
chose d'accord et m grivot en avant et
puis l'objectif c'était de faire oublier
tout ce qui se passerait au même moment
ailleurs en france
et de brandir cette victoire à paris
arraché au parti socialiste vous voyez
comme une espèce de victoire symbolique
qui aurait fait oublier tout le reste
le problème c'est que quand on monte ce
genre d'opération on échoue facilement
parce que ça devient tellement le voyez
le l'incitation à se présenter à paris
et elle
et puis le fait de pi2 de magouiller
parce que si c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
s'est passé là le processus de
désignation interne est tellement fort
que ça suscite des frustrations donc ça
a suscité lundi avec les deux villani
donc on est dans une manipulation on est
dans une espèce de sentiment de
sentiment qu'on peut justement on peut
tromper l'électeur est donc ça se
retourne un peu dans 50 0,32 à corbas
paris s'est rendu qu'à marcher avec
adidas qui n'est pas le cas dit
d'ailleurs ne s'est pas présenté à paris
c'est clair mais mais je veux que tu me
réponds tu parce que je crois qu'il n'a
pas compris mais c'est pas
c'est pas la théorie du complot le mode
de désignation des candidats
rappelons rappelons que en marche et un
d'abord à l'origine d'un mouvement
politique et pas un parti politique un
mouvement politique ou la double
appartenance a longtemps été autorisé
parce que moi j'étais adhérent dans
marché adhérents du parti socialiste
pendant très longtemps comme il y avait
des gens qui venaient de la droite et du
centre-droit et il y avait la double
appartenance et c'était dans les
premiers statuts de la république en
marche et ça a été autorisée très
longtemps ce qui explique aujourd'hui
que quand on a des partenaires de droite
et des partenaires de gauche qui se
retrouvait plus dans leurs familles
politiques traditionnelles et qui ont
décidé de croire en une nouvelle
aventure parce que les lignes ont changé
et on est entre des progressistes d'un
côté et on voit bien ce qu'on retrouve
ce qu'on retrouve de l'autre côté mais
vous me donnez tous l'impression de
découvrir l'autre chaîne ce soir oui les
municipales seront durs pour en marche
mais c'était écrit le soir de l'élection
d' emmanuel macron puisque toutes les
élections intermédiaires sont mauvaises
pour le pouvoir en place
patrick on l'a vécu ensemble au ps en
le ps a fait de mauvaises municipales en
est-ce que ça va aider par tous 0 et
lille ya zéro pas une règle d'or que lui
il ya zéro candidat sortant en marche en
france alors il a un gros but c'est que
les gens qui ont vu leurs marges alors
oui il ya des gens qui furent alors
match mais aucun candidat il ya 2500 élu
en 2004
et voilà il y aura deux mille cinq cents
élus et je pense qu'on marche aura à peu
près dix mille élus remarche
après
ces visées et ça sera année ça sera
phénoménal vous avez raison de dire que
cette élection intermédiaire est en
général difficile pour le pouvoir en
place
alors elle n'a pas toujours été et c'est
vrai que les ya quelques dans l'histoire
des élections municipales il ya deux
élections qui ont montré des vagues
d'opposition très forte celle de 77 avec
notamment une victoire importante des
socialistes qui préparait d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière la victoire
future de 80 il y avait des élections
sont 18 qui avait été un échec pour
l'union de la gauche mais ce sont 17 est
une élection extrêmement important pour
l'implantation de ce qu'on a appelé le
socialisme municipal
et puis vous avez eu 83 avec un refus il
a en effet de la gauche municipale et
une victoire de la droite de l'udf et le
rpr de l'époque
mais ceci dit quand même ce qui est
frappant aujourd'hui dans la stratégie
qui est la stratégie politique d'un
marche c'est que si vous voulez il n'ya
pas le seul le problème ce n'est pas
seulement que ce soit une élection
intermédiaire difficile pour le pouvoir
c'est que c'est aussi une élection
intermédiaire pour un président de la
république qui en difficulté avec le
local et qui a une difficulté avec les
collectivités locales
parce que tout simplement il est 8 même
il n'est pas issu de ce cursus honorum
qui est le cursus traditionnel delon
politique qui passe par les élections
locales et puis qui progressivement
progresse donc il a quand même d'une
certaine manière dans sa culture
politique une culture politique qui
n'est pas fondamentalement axée sur le
local et on voit aujourd'hui et on l'a
vu encore même lors du congrès de la
haye mais fou son discours on peut pas
le dire que son discours était quand
même largement entendu on l'a vu avec le
congrès des départements et les
relations compliquées il a des relations
compliquées avec les collectivités
locales donc si vous voulez le contexte
en tant que tel de la relation
aujourd'hui de la majorité au local rend
encore plus difficile cette élection
cette élection municipale et on voit
bien que la stratégie finalement est
très simple c'est vrai c'est d'essayer
de rendre illisibles les résultats
essayer de rendre les illisibles les
résultats et les enseignements nationaux
que l'on pourrait tirer de ce scrutin
mais je rajouterais que il n'est pas le
seul
parce que finalement quand on regarde
les sortants de ce que l'on appelle les
vieilles marques politique c'est à dire
autant des républicains que des partis
socialistes ils ne vont pas vraiment
faire campagne avec le drapeau et sa
venue
au lever ça fait très longtemps et vous
avez deux formations et vous avez
vraisemblablement deux formations qui
elles vont faire campagne
sous leurs propres sous leurs propres
couleurs et qui ont été à le faire c'est
d'un côté le rassemblement national et
de l'autre les verts qui eux veulent se
compter et veulent montrer qu'ils
deviennent des forces politiques qui
vont peser sur les scrutins à venir
patrick mennucci c'est vrai que peint
pour ce scrutin des municipales même les
partis traditionnels
alors pour l'anecdote et j'étais
candidat 1983 non je ne vis pas avec
gaston defferre
je n'ai pas le souvenir croyez moi que
j'ai collé des affiches à ce moment-là
n'ai pas le souvenir de voir le poing et
la rose sur la fiche que je colle je
sais que je marque je me souviens
surtout je faisais surtout deux ombres
et 80 je me souviens je me souviens je
me souviens qu'une somme le calice avait
une youm pour l'avenir de marseille mais
j'ai pas vu autonome ce que je veux dire
non mais ce que je veux dire africaine
pourquoi cette année mais parce que ses
traditions ses traditionnels donné les
élections municipales de mettre en avant
un rassemblement local
bilan si on est maire sortant soutenu
par x y z
la plupart la plupart des listes font
cela la plupart des listes fraude ça
c'est à dire oh ah ben non
et puis ambane dessous il y aura écrit
soutenu branché je ne veux pas de faire
du mauricianisme top de la soirée mais
je viens de voir la fiche du candidat de
la république en marche à marseille
monsieur berlin il faut une loupe pour
voir écrit en marche quelque part c'est
même lui qui totalement hugo nys est
d'ailleurs frappant
parce que moi je ferai les verts sz si
j'étais candidat en marche ce qu'à dieu
ne plaise
si j'étais candidat en marche je mettrai
en marche à laval si j'étais gosse que
parce que c'est un intérêt de le faire
mais je crois qu'elle fait l'annoncé le
social la république qu'on le veuille ou
non il avait déjà ce qu'ils votent pour
lui
est-ce que je tourne moins parler pour
dire que vous avez raison parce que je
pense que quand on est soutenu par le
rassemblement national ou d'autres
parties comme c'est le cas pour vous
qu'est ce que ça apporte finalement mais
vous le mettez nous choque absolument
bien d'autres la messe était bon mais de
toute façon c'est général souvent les
gens mettent le nom d'une liste voilà
avec un marseille par dessus tout paris
en avant etc
et puis en dessous les logos des partis
et paris ensuite vous avez des logos des
partis c'est une bombe
parallèlement une une cuisine
traditionnelle simplement savard parfois
plus loin quand on ne voit plus du tout
les logos ou alors qu'il devienne
microscopiques
ou alors que bon le logo lui-même ne
signifie pas grand chose bon ce qui
compte c'est la filiation qu'on indique
toujours sur ces fameux formulaire et
qui enregistre en préfecture et qui va
faire ensuite le total des voix
c'est ça qui compte et c'est ce qui
permet au ministère de l'intérieur
d'afficher des résultats et c'est là où
il ya manipulation parce que si vous
excluez voyez tout ce qui est en dessous
de 9 mille habitants ça va devenir bon
très difficile à interpréter une chanson
comme ça sera difficile à interpréter
c'est un mauvais calcul à nouveau du
gouvernement parce que y'aura y aura un
loup dans le flou d'accord et donc on
saura que seul ou à un peu le pelage de
la république en marche et que tout ça
dissimule quoi qu'il arrive ensuite on
pensera que c'est un échec traitement
qu'il faut long texto le rassemblement
national
le fait de ne pas m'avoir de 2-2-2
nombre d'étiquettes de liste sous 9000
habitants est une bonne opération
parce que leur ascendant sur dallas et
peu très peu de l'isof en occitanie et
dans le bassin minier mais juste c'est
quand même une situation c'est innovante
c'est la première fois que tous les
maires sortants quasiment à part les
quelques uns qui ont rallié la
république en marche se retrouve dans la
position de maire qu'ils ne sont pas
du pouvoir en place et donc bénéficions
tous de la prime de la prime au sortant
s'ils ont bien fait leur job sans avoir
de vote sanction du national sais pas
vous moi je trouvais analysé existe oui
oui quand on regarde les sondages à
nantes à rennes à clermont ferrand à
lille comme beaucoup d'autres villes âme
au monde
à saint-etienne on voit que les maires
sont ainsi long biên vélocité mellal
mais la plupart ne vient pas la plupart
des cas de rougeole et merci à paris à
paris actuellement tout le monde dit bon
anne hidalgo et en tête elle à 29,23
construit mais sans résultat d'un régime
particulier par arrondissement on va en
parler évidemment dans la deuxième
partie que de faux listings ce débat sur
la stratégie de la république en marche
pour les prochaines élections
municipales le parti parviendra t-il à
sont créés localement dans un paysage
politique en pleine transformation
on en parle de rang dans quelques
instants rester à vie
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir des français parce que selon
le crr instruments qu'ils ont de
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qu'ils
étaient faits entre pays africains et
sur lequel la france et l'europe avait
pas grand chose à dire en question au
nahd à paris les fixes avec non mais c
est ce que c'est la même monnaie
prochain le sujet aujourd'hui en afrique
c'est pas d'avoir une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de qui a entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
oui
mais
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce vivier un
peu dans la peur avec steam ou ce qui
est des menaces oui d intimidation comme
brûler les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment jeune ans je pense que j'y
croyais pas ceux qui ont été assassinés
étaient les politiques du journal il
était l'âme de ce journal et oui ils ont
tué charlie je voulais pas que tignes où
ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à huy qui nous la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
oh
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs patrick mennucci mme que
la bei et nos invités arnaud benedetti
spécialistes politiques et serge
federbusch candidat à la mairie de paris
sur la liste et mais paris on continue
donc ce débat sur les élections
municipales avec l'entrée dans la course
cette année de la république en marche
nicolas bay sont à vue des ministres
cette semaine se déclarer candidat pour
ces municipales c'est quoi c'est de
l'affichage on les élit et puis ensuite
il retourne au gouvernement avant toute
chose c'est une esthétique c'est le
vieux monde
seul le monde qu'il n'avait peut-être
pas que des mauvais côtés sur certaines
choses non du tout objectivement le
président a demandé à ses ministres
d'aller au combat parce que des
ministres qui sont candidats sans voix
un message envoie un message que le
président ait mis sont confiants de la
politique menée et qui n'ont pas peur
d'aller d'aller sur le terrain se
confronter aux électeurs et c'est le
symbole c'est le symbole qui est
demandée quand on dit un ministre va au
combat dans une ville c'est pas va
forcément gagner 1000 c va montrer que
tu es fier de ton travail il va montrer
que tu es alors je dis je savais
l'élection de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron a aussi de prouver que les
français en avaient peut-être marre
des têtes d'affiché de ce vieux système
moi j'ai connu
parce que je viens d'un parent d'une
famille politique avant qui était la
grande spécialiste des parachutages et
et on avait des mini ce qui arrivait du
jour au lendemain dans une commune et
qui repartaient sans lendemain là moi ce
que j'attends des ministres en marche
qu'ils soient candidats s'ils sont élus
ou dans des majorités municipales ou
dans des oppositions municipales c'est
qu'il reste et qui prennent un ancrage
sur les territoires où ils vont
maintenant
mais est-ce que c'était prévu didier
guillaume et l'ordre ministres qui sont
qui s'affrontera biarritz qu'est-ce
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose là qui
dit de l'organisation du parti coup mais
c'est un parti normal suite a dans un
premier temps qui est plutôt mal vu
d'ailleurs par les électeurs lors de ces
municipales arnaud benedetti
ça sert à quoi le parachutage
concrètement le parachutage sa recherche
un candidat à se trouver une terre
électorale qui soit une terre électorale
propice pour qu'il puisse se faire élire
mais vous savez le parachutage était un
exercice extrêmement difficile il ya des
parachutages qui ont parfois très mal
terminé alors c'est vrai que didier
guillaume c'est assez surprenant parce
qu'en plus bon biarritz et c'est une
ville avec une identité dans une région
qui a une forte identité
ce parachutage de dire à première vue
que peut surprendre
ça fait donc franchement dans cette
élection alors qu'on sait en plein de
réforme des retraites
une certaine de toute façon on mesurera
quand même le résultat des ministres qui
sont candidats et ressasse cela je veux
dire on évalue à un moment donné leur
degré leur degré de réussite électorale
ou pas ce jeune homme quand même qui a
très peu il ya quand même il ya quand
même très peu de ministres qui vont au
combat
est ce qu'ils vont répondre au combat
vont essentiellement quand même dans une
métropole de confort qui est celle de
paris ou quand même il est beaucoup plus
facile pour un ministre venons d'en
marge de l'arrivée d'un tel que d'aller
dans le change en tant que d'aller dans
le four du comtal ou même à marseille
nous avons été prise ils ont été
prisonniers d'une illusion en fait les
gens de la république en marche à paris
c'est effectivement de considérer que le
score qui avait été fait par donc la
liste de l'oiseau on a déjà pratiquement
oubliée elle a tellement pris son envol
qu'on a déjà oublié son nom donc de la
république en marge aux élections
européennes et bien leur assurer une
espèce de deux d'élections triomphal et
d'ailleurs ça aboutit une espèce de
panique dans les rangs des républicains
avec des gens qui comme florence
berthaud dans le 5e arrondissement qui
présidait le groupe ait l'air au conseil
de paris qui jour au lendemain mais du
jour au lendemain a déserté donc ça a
été il ya eu une espèce des faits
révélateurs des faibles convictions des
uns et des autres sauf qu'entre temps
les choses ont changé ce qui avait
motivé le score tout à fait est élevé de
la république en marche à paris au
moment des européennes c'est la peur la
peur de ce qui s'était passé au moment
dé gilet jaune surtout dans la barrique
l'ouest c'est très clair on pourrait
corrélés le vote la république en marche
avec la quantité de gaz lacrymogène
déversés par la police
moi j'attends elle aurait plutôt
équitable à droite là où il ya le plus
de manifestations
c'est le 8ème arrondissement c'est le
score le plus élevé est bon en suisse et
7e arrondissements là où il y avait eu
des buts non non mais je pense que tu as
fait c'est vrai que cette analyse il ya
une sociologie et sociologie il ya quand
même eu sociaux il ya une sociologie il
ya une sociologie à paris qui est quand
même fondamentalement apprécié ford qui
font qu'il ya une sociologie à paris qui
fondamentalement adhèrent aux valeurs de
la république en marche pour la vue lors
des élections présidentielles ça on l'a
vu lors des élections européennes
et ce qui est fondamentalement
incompréhensible sur un plan j'allais
dire presque professionnel au plan
politique c'est que la république en
marche ce soit aussi mal organisés pour
se retrouver dans cette situation
avec finalement deux candidatures une
candidature dissidente qui est celle de
cédric villani la capture de benjamin
griveaux ces lots a cessé les marcheurs
des débuts qui voudraient aussi avec
pourquoi c'est pas qu'il dise pourquoi
moi pourquoi pas moi alors que c'est la
seule jean-marie dynamique des candidats
d'autres partis d'ailleurs quoi le point
de référence excusez moi le point de
référence et le score de en fait de
fillon premier tour et il ya quand même
pas aux européennes
donc dans là le pari de droite classique
de droite bourgeois classique de l'ouest
il ya une montée très très forte entre
le score de fillon premier tour de la
présidentielle et le score de la liste
l'oiseau aux européennes est donc cette
demande est très forte s'explique ça
j'en suis absolument persuadé gelé
j'arpente suffisamment le terrain
politique parisien pour le concevoir que
c'est lié au traumatisme de la crise des
gilets jaunes dans l'ouest parisien
s'est offert deux puissants troisième
disons qu'il ya eu des émeutes anglaises
justement sur ces ministres qui se
présente sous la même étiquette sous
l'étiquette la république en match en
l'occurrence écouter le rappel à l'ordre
d'edouard philippe cette semaine c'était
mercredi
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire aux membres
du gouvernement qu'elle était les règles
pour se présenter aux élections
municipales
j'ai eu aussi l'occasion de dire à ceux
qui se trouvaient dans la situation
peut-être baroque
vous évoquez qu' à l'évidence il n'était
pas envisageable que deux membres d'un
même gouvernement puisse se présenter
l'un contre l'autre durablement j'ai
beaucoup l'occasion de le dire avec à la
fois beaucoup d'amitié et beaucoup d
estime pour ce que vous désignez mais
aussi avec beaucoup de fierté que les
belles réactions comment est-ce que à
paris notamment ça va être départagés
ces candidatures selon vous on attend il
doit fil avec ton pour herman il s'est
dit on va attendre de voir qui a la
meilleure chance de sortir d'arrêter on
choisira ce moment là je sais pas si mon
verdol le moyen de prévenir l'avenir
mais non il va falloir choisir
juste ce qui va se passer c'est qu'il va
être d'abord y avoir un premier tour de
l'élection municipale et que l'aïkido
candidats ont rappelé on bat pas avec
les deux candidats avec les candidats
des candidats puisqu'on est à paris et
que c'est un vote d'arrondissement et
que chaque candidat d'ailleurs villani
le fait pas dans tous les
arrondissements chaque candidat à une
liste et on les électeurs des
arrondissements parisiens de votre
d'abord pour un maire d'arrondissement
ils disent d'arrondissement alors vous
voulez dire quoi il sera pas présent
dans tous les arrondissements
je pense pas qu'ils aient des lices
villani 35 ans 10 à la république en
marche mais il y aura des alliances au
second tour on verra comment
ce front se feront les alliances alors
c'est par ici se divise sur paris hier
mais tu es fait souvent dominati et
c'est encore en marche puisque cédric
villani et un démarcheur de la première
heure comme vous pourquoi les refuser
cette c'est un match que nous aussi on
est un marcheur de la première heure les
deux sont des marchands y
on a essayé je pense qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses réunions pour essayer de les
concilier moment quand les deux veulent
aller jusqu'au bout vous pouvez être qui
vous voulez vous ne pouvez pas les
empêcher d'aller jusqu'au bout et quand
après après ce que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que il ya quand même quelques
ministres qui vont dans des territoires
d'élections à gérald darmanin à
tourcoing on à sébastien lecornu dans
l'heure qui sont chez eux qui sont déjà
des démunis seront créés on à gabriella
talent qui va à vendre voilà vous avez
tous les ministres ne vont pas tous les
ministres vont pas à paris je pense que
les ministres vont apparier par une ou
deux exceptions sont des ministres qui
étaient parisiens
voilà le cas de christian jacot qui a
été exclu de la république en marche
parce qu'il n'a pas été investi on lui a
préféré un nombre de lui dit qu'est ce
que ça dit de de la politique de la
république en marche qui se voulait une
nouvelle politique justement avec voilà
c'est aussi un calcul politique selon
vous a renouvellé betty comme vous
l'avez dit vous savez le vieux monde le
vieux monde existe les pratiques
politiques finalement ne change pas mais
ça si vous voulez ça traduit encore une
fois l'illisibilité de cette stratégie
fondamentalement c'est à dire qu' il ya
des calculs d'opportunités qui sont
faits en fonction des situations locales
alors ça je vous la corde ce n'est pas
propre à la république en marche à
exister dans toutes les formations
politiques depuis que les élections
municipales existe depuis que les
élections d'ailleurs existe il ya un
moment donné ont choisi des candidats
dont on semble qu'ils ne tentent ils
parient notamment qu'il apparaisse
oui mais c'est déjà arrivé c'est déjà
arrivé dans d'autres circonstances bon
l'uni n'est pas quand même très loin de
la république en marche jusqu'à preuve
du contraire d'eau que en l'occurrence
mais qu'ils essayent d'avoir eu une
position une position autonome
donc si vous voulez ça qu'est ce que ça
dit ça dit tout simplement que la
république en marche
manque manque de cadres politiques
locaux pour mener des batailles locales
et des batailles municipal et que le
vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est la
question de l'implantation mais que
l'importation va être extrêmement
difficile alors parce que tout
simplement de dire d'implantation elle
se fait au moment d'une élection
intermédiaire non non je jouerai revenir
sur la sociologie parisienne parce que
je pense que c'est quand même important
par ici ça me parait nanomètres les
côtés oui mais goûter ou si on est passé
pas pour les marseillais ce qui me
paraît clair c'est qu'est ce qui est de
mouvements profonds du maquereau nisme
et de la politique qu'ils m'aiment parce
que tout ça est lié à la politique comme
elle sait que le président république
souhaite pour 2000
tous deux disent on être le candidat de
la droite pour cela il mène un centre
droit vous avez raison humaine donc une
certaine politique or pas revenir sur ce
qui se passe ou la façon dont ont été
gérés les jeunes mais à paris sa des
conséquences qui sont évidentes je paie
pour désherber où je suis pas sûr que ce
soit dû aux simplement aux gaz
lacrymogènes
il me semble qu'on peut corréler permet
on peut corréler vous l'avait déjà
révélé
monsieur on peut comprendre corrélés je
crois beaucoup plus sérieusement le
score de la liste de madame l'oiseau à
paris avec le score de la liste fille au
plus la liste fioul était élevé à paris
dans le viiie arrondissement où elle
résonne dans le xvième dans le 7e plus
la liste de la république en marche a
été levée et je veux pour preuve que ce
n'est pas spécifique à paris c'est
spécifique à toutes les villes où à tous
les secteurs de vivre lyon marseille est
roi où la droite est été dominante
il y a donc une espèce d'aspiration
entre la république en marche et
l'électorat de droite et ça a des
conséquences sam est conséquent mais
signaux histoire et quel genre est
permis film est pour vous avez les bons
sinon si vous avez lu débat ça devient
je suis pas sûr si on comptabilise et
les minutes que vous serez mais voilà
soutien je fume bien sûr de mes jeux
combats voilà donc je pense que ça
vienne de là c'est une question
sociologique est juste le dernier mot
sur biarritz attention moi jouer un
trône avec tout le monde didier
guillaume n'est pas parachutée à
biarritz et guillaume sa femme et
professeur à biarritz guillaume habite à
biarritz depuis cinq ans est candidat
mais il faut il ou non mais je voudrais
pas qu'on dise voilà il faut être
honnête avec la réalité des libertés ce
courant bah oui ben si possible donc sur
les questions de des scores fillon à
paris ensuite des scores de la
république en marche aux européennes je
crois que le score de bellamy aurait pu
être plus élevé il avait une sociologie
un type 1 type qui aurait pu plaire donc
c'est vraiment je crois que ça a été
corrélée avec une peur de l'ouest
parisien qu'il n'avait jamais connu des
meutes depuis 140 ans depuis la commune
deuxièmement et diamants 150 depuis donc
maintenant sur le villani leucate
villani ce que ça révèle je crois que
c'est très intéressant
ce qui est très intéressant c'est qu'ils
ne soient pas exclus voyez du parti
parce que bon eu un vote soit disant
unanime de la commission d'investiture
et puis ensuite immédiatement bravache
il se présente dans un parti normalement
constitué surtout dans la première ville
de france dans les capitales ça se pose
ça se traduit par une exclusion
le fait de ne pas l'exclure ça montre
quand même une grande faiblesse une
grande fragilité
bon alors ils ont cru peut-être au
départ qui se dégonfle aurait comme une
baudruche et qu'il pourrait le récupérer
que c'était juste une aventure solitaire
de quelques jours ou quelques semaines
et que son orgueil un peu apaisées bon
puits sont rendus compte que c'était pas
ça et dans ce cas là il ya un vrai
problème politique et je dirais à
nouveau il faut pas trop fine assez il
faut pas trop chercher à prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles mais comme ils
ont tendance à penser qu'ils ont une
espèce de supériorité qui leur permet de
manipuler les uns et les autres ils
n'ont pas posé le problème véritablement
il aurait dû être exclu de la république
en marche et les choses serait beaucoup
plus simple aujourd'hui pour eux alors
loi les croyait
une étude très intéressante dans le jdd
dimanche dernier sur le report justement
des voix des partis traditionnels sur la
république en marche et ce qui peut être
aussi un indicateur pour ces municipales
34% de la droite vers la république en
marche
les électeurs du rassemblement national
dans les communes de moins de 5000
habitants n'est pas tellement impacté et
finalement par par ce report des voix
depuis l'existence de la république en
marche un peu effectivement vous le
voyez à l'écran et puis le choix de
l'abstention notamment pour les sans
étiquette as 49% donc les
abstentionnistes voilà pour pour ces
résultats c'est vrai que le paysage
politique est complètement différent
pour ces municipales est ce que c'est la
fin ce à quoi nous assistons quand même
et là je rejoins patrick mennucci c'est
que healy a aujourd'hui une
transformation de la sociologie
électorale du maquereau nisme c'est à
dire que c'est finalement macron il a
été élu il est parti du centre gauche il
a été élu globalement plutôt par un
électorat de centre gauche plutôt
socialiste qui voulait faire barrage
notamment à marine le pen donc mais on
voit bien à partir des élections
européennes que non pas seulement dans
l'ouest parisien c'est pour ça que je
suis pas du tout à fait d'accord avec
vos thèses de considérer que finalement
l'épisode et gilet jaune a joué un rôle
dans le vote d'une partie de la droite
vers la vérité c'est que la sociologie
aujourd'hui électoral de la république
en marche c'est une sociologie
électorale que l'on qualifie dans
l'histoire des droites d'organiste de
centre droit c'est l'ancienne udf
finalement aujourd'hui c'est sa l'offre
politique de d'emmanuel macro et il a
très bien compris d'ailleurs s'y tient
aujourd'hui qu'on me tienne sur le
dossier des retraites c'est parce qu'il
a compris que c'était un marqueur
politique extrêmement fort pour cette
pour cet électorat là est d'ailleurs
allé voir les résultats de suresnes
et là il ya une personne n'y a pas eu de
y'a pas eu de gilet jaune dans le parc
de cette bouche compact et beaucoup de
joie et beaucoup plus vers ces communes
en france va jouer sur ces municipales
et notamment sur l'abstention
nicolas bay sans vous c'est sûr qu'à des
anges
il ya des territoires qui sont oubliées
aujourd'hui dans la république est le
président et le gouvernement ont pris
des mesures notamment sur des ouvertures
mais l'ouverture de maisons de service
public
je peux en parler puisque j'avais été
rapporteur quand j'étais parlementaire
sur les services publics itinérant et il
ya un sentiment d'abandon des
territoires qui est souvent d'ailleurs
qu'un sentiment des territoires n'ont
pas été abandonnées il ya un sentiment
d'abandon par rapport aux grandes villes
moi je suis allé dans des villages au
moment de ma mission parlementaire on
disait oui on a plus de on a plus de
gendarmerie on a plus poste mais il les
avait jamais eus
sauf qu'aujourd'hui à ce sentiment
d'abandon des territoires qui fait qu'il
ya une forme de repli sur soi et ça mène
à un vote vert vers les extrêmes
j'aimerais juste rappeler une chose sur
les élus qui seront élus en marche au
municipal au mois de mars
comme pour les députés on aura un
renouvellement de la classe politique il
faut rappeler que 90 % plus de 90% des
élus en marche aux élections municipales
sont des gens qui seront néophyte en
politique et pour qui ce sera la
première élection en marche a quand même
renouveler l'offre politique et je suis
assez surpris que vous essayez tous deux
classés
le président de la république
centre-droit centre gauche
on verra bien où il sera en 2022 moi je
pense que les anciens clivages sont
cassés je suis de ceux qui pensent que
les anciens clivages sont cassées et je
vais vous dire en tout cas et je peux
vous dire que dans la vraie politique
dans le bassin de santos improbable
du pas de calais d'où je viens les
électeurs qui me parlent n'attendait
qu'une chose c'est qu'on en finisse avec
la politique
un petit gars l'ancienne et la droite et
la gauche ne veut plus rien
j'espère d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
une chose c'est pas c'est pas emmanuel
macron qui a un qui a inventé en marche
et ce qui est en marche aujourd'hui
c'est des maires de villages qui ont
inventé ça il ya des années en prenant
l'agriculteur de droite et en prenons
l'instituteur deux heures et on l'aimé
tant et en émettant sur les mêmes listes
c'est la jeunesse de matisse et 17 de ce
sont des jeunes avec l'argent liquide
dernières éditions il m'a passé au
pourquoi les occupants et le bonheur et
d'anthony qui seraient publiques en leur
marché l'émanation du cac 40 c'est tout
c'est ça qui compte bo est votre
président emmanuel macron mais c'est pas
là c'est au service qui vous savez et
aimez pas du tout même si de voir le
comportement et les relations entre
macron et bernard arnault et la
proximité avec bernard arnault qui est
l'homme le plus riche de france un des
plus riches du monde aujourd'hui
pour le comprendre c'est une évidence et
le candidat du secondaire ces milliards
mais pas jusqu'à mai
quelque chose au sujet de la taxe de la
république en marche crête et demain
qu'on bon moi c'est quelque chose qui me
qui mérite sans doute qu'on s'y arrête
et qu'on essaie de le comprendre j'ai
l'impression que c'est un système
politique qui fonctionne un peu dans la
tension et la tension des gilets jaunes
quoi que vous disiez à jouer au bénéfice
de la recherche fait d'accord non mais
là il ya une nouvelle tension et j'ai
l'impression que le fait de la stratégie
de la tension de laisser aussi pourrir
la situation sur les retraites c'est un
peu là roger lacoste de légitimité
légitimiste la principale non non mais
c'est non mais c'est très bien qu'il
allait prendre cette attitré la tenue de
la de l'écran paraît est ce que ces
municipales c'est un test pour emmanuel
macron pour les 2012 je crois que c'est
un test mais vous voyez bien que tout le
travail de la république en marche
depuis des mois c'est de déconstruire le
test et ex y compris ce que vient de
dire nicolas bays depuis une heure c'est
à dire que c'est de rendre l'élection
municipale qu'on va me dire ça aux open
effets sur le gouvernement
le je vous rappelle quand même que à
l'issue des élections municipales de
2014 qui ont été très mauvaises et je
peux me parler en connaissance de cause
qu'ils ont été très mauvaises pour le
parti socialiste le gouvernement et
échanger le premier ministre a été
changé il ya des mouvements politiques
qui sont apparues là on comprend que ce
que fait manuel va qu'on sait quel que
soit ce qu'il arrive ces élections
municipales mais il continuera à
appliquer sa politique
je pense que c'est une bonne chose le
décor et moi c'est une pure analyse je
fais
ces indemnités ça sera un demi test mais
parce qu'on verra si la république en
marché capable de s'implanter ce qui va
être difficile on verra aussi la
capacité du rassemblement national a
éventuellement multiplié son score dans
un certain nombre de territoires et des
verts ça sera aussi là ça sera des
textes anciens
là on aura des tests importants mais moi
je pense que le véritable test avant
l'élection présidentielle ce sera un
action régionale c'est là qu'on ait fait
déjà là on va voir ce qui va se passer
au niveau de lecture régional comment la
république en marche va construire son
offre dans les différentes régions et
finalement est ce que c'est ça va on va
rencontrer l'assentiment des électrices
est beaucoup plus favorable à la
république en marche les régionales
beaucoup plus être organisé que des
municipales merci beaucoup c'est l'heure
du coup de gueule à présent du coup de
coeur
[Musique]
et un coup de gueule pour vous patrick
mennucci pour l'intrusion de quelques
individus au siège de la cfdt qualifiées
de violente par laurent berger est
contredite par la coordination sais je
suis scandalisée je suis absolument
scandalisé que dans le débat politique
et syndical des retraites y ait des
jeunes qui est l'idée de rentrer dans
les locaux d'une coopération se divertir
la première confédération syndicale du
pays pour même si ça n'a pas été d'une
violence extrême
c'est le fait simplement de le faire et
d'une violence insupportable et je pense
qu'il faut que tout le monde est
bienvenu
verdier jésus martinez je crois qu'ils
ont raison de dénoncer ce qui s'est
passé parce que c'est la démocratie
française alors là c'est la république
qui est un individu déjà les
organisations syndicales sont d'enfance
plus faible que dans les autres
démocraties occidentales européennes
je crois voilà donc je pense vraiment
que c'est en tout ce qui s'est passé à
l'égard de la cfdt
quoi qu'on pense de la position de la
cfdt dans le débat sur les retraites par
exemple et pour vous nicolas bay c'est à
cette semaine vous dénoncé une
stigmatisation des policiers oui ça
m'insupporte quand on attaque
cette institution avec les violences
policières il peut y avoir des violences
deux policiers si c'est pas des
violences policières certains
complotistes parle de milices au service
du gouvernement non il ya des quelques
débordements de la part de certains
policiers
moi je me souviens en 2015 olitique août
est de maintien de l'ordre qui les
guenons non non j'aimerais finir
j'aimerais surtout qu'on le laisse finir
parce que ça donne cette image là ses
discours politique
un affaiblissent la police de deux en
plus d'affaiblir la police on laisse
sous-entendre des choses les peler les
policiers seraient inattaquable il faut
rappeler qu'en 2017 l'igpn a prononcé
plus de 2000 sanctions en 2010 8800
sanctions sur des policiers ça va de la
révocation jusqu'à des transferts au
parc et donc les policiers ne sont pas
ne sont pas inattaquable
les policiers qui commettent des
violences ou des who ou des actes
délictueux sont poursuivies mais
l'intégrité russie et jaune ont été on a
vu le jour au lancement également mais
effectivement donc c'est qu'il y avait
un problème il fallait peut-être
crèmerie mais un problème de la part de
gens s'y attend pas d'institution on
entend de plus en plus souvent le
terrain de complotiste dans la bouche
des macros nist et je trouve que c'est
mauvais mauvais signe pour eux parce que
de dénoncer le complotisme partout ça
veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui
sont mauvais dans votre royaume on a
beau je suis d'accord et que je pense
que vous appartenez le formation
portista vient de ce qu'on va en parler
demain justement de cette semaine ils
sont bons sur les violences deux
policiers dont parlait nicolas bes
rester avec nous à suivre l'info sur rt
france
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés